cheep-cheep-cheep hi guys
hi bubbles hi Walter hi dolly hey mama
hi baby hi Albie Janie's farm didn't
start out with animals that were missing
limbs it just happened to come to her
farm and she felt well prosthetic
technologies helped me it could
certainly help them I can't imagine not
having an artificial leg because I lost
my leg at ten and I'm quite used to it
it's thanks to medical science that I'm
able to live this normal life and for
these animals
I want no different for them hi Felix
what comes on it Woodstock Farm
Sanctuary on daily basis we're home to
right now around 300 rescued farm
animals they've all come from bad places
and they get the veterinary care the
health care that they need on a daily
basis my bestest she's feisty can you
come help me with Felix they're all
actually in the front pasture little
Felix came to us as a as a baby lamb and
he had come from a big sheep farm and
overnight some sort of predator had
gotten in and they found little Felix
with his leg chewed off and so I spoke
to my prosthetist the gentleman who
makes my legs Erik I don't know if many
clinicians would have went out to the
farm I don't have any experience with
fitting prosthetics on animals very few
people in the country do so I figured if
I could take what knowledge that I do
have and apply it to the animal I could
probably get them to utilize the
prosthesis and it wasn't until we got
hooked up with SUNY New Paltz and their
3d printing lab that we were able to
make something pretty cool and
cutting-edge for him
seeing him walk on the leg was
absolutely amazing from my limited
interactions with him he isn't
necessarily the most outgoing sheep in
the world it's actually very sheepish
but what he ended up doing was he
started running away from us which was
amazing
we were just jumping for joy that he
could actually get up and run keep up
with his flock he looked like he was a
very happy sheep if we could do this
more on other animals we wouldn't have
to you know put them down
most of the world doesn't fully
understand it they think of them as just
farmed animals but we hope that that
changes and that's part of the magic of
what we do here they get pastures to
roam in access to the Sun and to the
grass they live life the way they were
intended to live there's no greater joy
goodie we can grow giant models for foot
in a month the 45 inches these models
would taste exactly the same as a normal
model nice and tender lush some of them
look a bit tough but once you cut into
them they cut like butter my name is
Philip Paul's I live in San Ari Wales
and I grow giant vegetables
I've been growing giant vegetables now
for the last 30 years I come from a very
large family
my mother had 17 children 13 of us
survived and I think you know that was
something you know big vegetables feed
big families you know I'm up here every
morning every night every single day of
the week
there's a lot of love and cake was into
it sometimes I do better talking to them
as well
to encourage them to grow which is a bit
of a bit of fun no I think he's just
about finished growing there now I got
to be very careful the wife is not about
when I start talking to my vegetables
but it's all good fun I broke the world
record for the heaviest cucumber what 25
years ago it radiates in a half pound
and it was just incredible the way true
you know when I started if we had a
Morrow 20 30 pound in weight you are the
base model now we're up over hundred
pound in weight normal cabbage would be
two pounding weights but we have grown
on hundred and twenty pound you know you
can feed 120 hundreds to 240 people off
one cabbage this is why I supply the
local pub and they use a map for Sunday
lunch I've developed my own strain more
or less now I select my own seed every
year the biggest and the best seed and
it just seems to be improving which is
incredible I grow organically I do think
if I can do it anybody can do it
and it's a big thrill every day the wife
say what am i doing up a lot but every
day and when she comes up she realised
water is just such an amazing medium
you can just see the crystals and how
they'd form in so many different ways
and then take that and extrapolate it to
these huge cliffs what we do here is
create spray ice and probably make over
300 different climbs my name is
Alexander Bianchi and I'm an ice farmer
we're down here in the uncompacted orge
we have a water system at the top of the
gorge these galvanized steel showerheads
and basically just sprays water out over
the cliffs and overnight when it's cold
it forms ice along the cliffs what we
really want is a nice clean surface for
the new water to come down and just keep
building off of that so a lot of what we
do here actually is rappel down a lot of
these faces and just try to clear that
snow off ready for the next layer
there's about two miles of ice if you
walk the bottom of the canyon and oh
yeah we farm ice all on the top of it
the ice farmers kind of hard work we're
going to open up the South valve
sometimes I think we're no more than
like glorified plumbers
ice farming is our and engineering I
mean the two I think are always really
inseparable
you know the engineering is the
logistics how do we get the water from
point A to point B sometimes if the
valves aren't cracked quite enough and
you get a little bit of a freeze up the
water doesn't get to develop the remedy
is a blowtorch
we had artistic side is once we have
this water where we need it how can we
do something different how can we make
something interesting that you know
we've never climbed before it's
definitely artistic process for some of
us I grew up rock climbing you know
fair-weather climber first time I came
out here was just kind of blown away
it's so different than rock climbing
you're climbing a transient medium the
rock is always going to be there this
this ice is not always there so it
creates this diversity and this intense
experience that I really don't find in
other facets of climbing and that's why
I'm proud to do what I'm doing Oh
Isabella Johnny need any personal ties
with there sit obscurity see if in refit
while
a lot rasuu teams Lamia fastened
opposition PMO's Lord appeared autonomy
get a DNA sample upon Segovia Cielo
neighs Lucian piane visitor Asami lapel
Oren Mallory just showcase Marie Soto
molester Hagia Sophia
yep all decodable or cat salmon cat bone
cement monopod ricasso hirotaro
Oh No Tsutomu give a premium for Lisa's
ponzu risotto but no male technique
industrial metal alloys well Eric style
suggest an idea when answer easily
generate Authority curriculum a
pedometer that is a commercial producer
Guan you can create the formula Jitsu
the area on a metal traditional machine
- Jacques illicit activity de su
material mo sabotage opportunity Patil
Cheniere doesn't remediation pianist or
operate a shopkin is me a bomb isn't
good laughing ah Xiu knowledge on easy
way pass cubic is any Content ID
recommendation pijo I feel keenly a
burpee Nobuko champion elfonzo film he
sailed a large Basia to toss away give a
spell
kill a visit or secon reevaluate so
champion he solitaire to PT will ready
to dissolve was here I was here was here
yeah they evacuated today was at
Cottonwood have waves retiring but I ate
a BFA
there's three things that are most
important to chefs first is flavor
second has flavor and third is flavor
flavor rules
built on the Fertile former lakebottom
soil of northern Ohio the chef's garden
is a 300 acre family farm that grows
specialty produce for some of the
world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases we're working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farm grows produce of all shapes and
sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens but the Jones
family wasn't always the chef's garden
my parents had had some very successful
years in 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm and ultimately the
farm collapsed
we were dealt a new deck of cards and
found opportunity within a disaster
we met a European influence chef
iris Balin to grow me varieties for
flavor grow me varieties without
chemical I want a zucchini bloom thought
this lady was absolutely crazy little do
we know she knew a heck of a lot more
about it than we did and that really
opened our eyes to another whole world
out there we hooked up with some really
great chefs early on folks like Danielle
Beaulieu and jean-georges Vongerichten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Rashard and
then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and in ritz-carlton chefs and for
seasoned chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture we're indebted
to those chefs that have given us the
privilege and the path to be able to
follow our dream of farming so it's that
symbiotic relationship of chef and
farmer working together for the greater
good and here we are 35 years later
still working to get better to the best
of our ability right now in this place I
think we're doing the right thing and I
think that trumps every other reason for
whatever you do in this life